سوف يقوم في مكان صغير جدًا بغارات جوية
بالمدفعية وقذائف الهاون التي تمطر
على ما يسمى بالمملكة البائسة للدول الإسلامية التي
تحولت إلى مجموعة خشنة
من الخيام دمرت السيارات والشاحنات
ربما نصف ميل مربع فقط على الرغم
من الهجوم الذي يبدو أن بينيت
يمكن رؤيته  المشي على طول
الخيام تخلت القوى الديمقراطية السورية المدعومة من الولايات المتحدة
عن محاولة تقدير عدد
الأشخاص الذين يقولون إن جميع المقاتلين لا يزالون
هناك ، أعني أنهم محاصرون
ويفوقون عددهم ويتفوقون على الهزيمة النهائية
تبدو وشيكة لكنهم يقاتلون على
قناعة ربما
سيسمح التدخل الإلهي  لانتزاع
النصر من بين فكي الهزيمة ، كل
الدلائل تشير إلى أن هذه المعركة
لن تنتهي اليوم أو غدًا كما قال
الرئيس ترامب عندما أخبرنا القائد
أنه ربما ستنتهي في غضون أربعة أو خمسة
أيام في المساء تجهز قوات سوريا الديمقراطية
أسلحتها لها.  المعركة التي تستمر في
القصف على مدار الساعة ليس هناك
راحة لآخر معاقل منتصف الليل
والأرض تهتز
ليلا في يومنا هذا.  يستمر الضحك ، حيث
تعيش داعش برصاصة في الحظيرة
وبواسطة الرصاصة في الحظيرة تموت